previously on TV sins
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is out is one of the single most
enjoyable experiences of life from the
couch I can tell you that out is
absolutely not even on the top-five list
of enjoyable experiences in life just
real quick
sex Pizza Pizza after sex sex after
pizza and sex pizza and I didn't even
get to roller coasters many people
forget the show was called Seinfeld
chronicles and for a good reason
this title makes the show sound like
it's actually about something super glad
you cleared that up for me I was very
confused about where I was and why I was
wasting my time on this triple bar
you've reminded me of my mistake and as
a sign of appreciation I'll remain
seated until this mediocre stand-up
segment has concluded
unless you count the debt collector I'm
pretty sure nobody is wondering where I
am - hi Jerry
you are literally wearing a t-shirt that
is clamping your trachea shut a quarter
inch from your Adam's apple worry about
your own wardrobe also which button is
he actually talking about he mentions
the second button but I think he's
actually referring to the top button and
not giving the collar button its own
designation which it has to have because
that's only used in the event of a tie
or an ed Grimley impersonation Seinfeld
didn't quite know how to Seinfeld yet
yep in honor of mr. Feld we will
continue to pound this clothing thing
into the pavement what's the deal with
wearing text-based t-shirts under an
over shirt is no one else distracted by
the perp eking out even if I'm smart
enough to deduce that it's a property of
t-shirt property of what whose property
is he
welcome to the expositional cafe where
we make sure our servers call you by
name each time they pour your coffee
just in case an audience is meeting them
for the first time that's because no one
has any interest in seeing you on
caffeine George is now holding a cup of
coffee
even though Clara never poured it and he
never picked up a cup in the previous
shop there's a reason these two
statements are usually kept apart God
doesn't bless devils everybody knows
that they were clearly not able to
afford the best extras at this point was
this guy reacting to to be fair he
hadn't done that guest spot on Criminal
Minds yet he's got everything he's got
detergent sprays fabric softeners this
is not his first load are they making
fun of a man who came to the laundromat
prepared to do laundry why is this funny
it is literally
expect it also does Jerry even have an
inside voice to one of these characters
made it to episodes without getting
accosted by someone who was tired of
hearing their extraneous conversations
revisiting this conversation literally
brought George to his knees that's
called acting ladies and gentleman
well technically overacting but it's
still the form of acting also if I ever
had a friend drop to their knees and beg
me to stop talking I think that might be
the end of our friendship this woman
spends four seconds fully pouring liquid
detergent into the washer and it's now
seemingly confused close the lid and
start the water okay reach on in there
with your hands and mush it all around
that's what normal people do yep and
then take those icky hands and touch
clean laundry also it says a lot when
the main characters interaction is so
boring I would rather judge laundry
technique show has a laugh track
seriously Costanza just snapped a few
times and we get two full seconds of
guffaws you can't all die you can't
overdrive but you can over line over
sign over hi or so I hear laundry day is
the only exciting day in the life of
clothes another absolute statement that
is false buy clothes hate laundry day
because it means the individuality they
express through stains and smells is
washed away by outta my clothes by
rewiring them until I offend someone so
terribly they wash the clothes for me
the washing machine is the nightclub of
clothes you know it's dark there's
bubbles happening they're all kind of
dancing around and they're Jerry
Seinfeld taught me that bubble raves
were born in 89 when people did the
thumbs out hitchike twist so they're
showing me on television the detergents
for getting out bloodstains is this a
violent image to anybody bloodstains
Gary's clearly never had a bloody nose a
nice grape child or a girlfriend
sweatpants Jerry is in the very
definition of lounge clothes how is he
so uncomfortable that he needs to untuck
cotton from cotton this is clearly Barry
beat benson flexing on Robin Williams
for the hairy man of 1989 award Kessler
he just called him Kessler and now I
have no choice but to believe that
Kramer has an identical twin named
Kessler that lived next to Jerry for a
single episode in 1989 he then
disappeared mysteriously and was never
mentioned again I suspect George human
contact all night to watch this
considering no actual humans or Mets
fans this shouldn't have been that hard
I know people say this is a show about
nothing like it's a compliment but we're
ten minutes into this thing and if it's
not going to be that funny I'd actually
like the show to be about at least a
little bit of something not sure how
Kessler is reacting to a game that Jerry
clearly paused a few seconds ago and
never unpause do you want ants because
this is how you get ants that was her
she wants to stay here
Oh 1989 when the statement was
compelling enough to cut the commercial
[Music]
it's quite possible the best thing the
show ever dude and the later episodes
was ditch this music my father was
moving this you have to have a cigarette
in his mouth the whole way yeah
Aaron's got to come down first he's you
now drop it down drop it down urines got
to come down is it me
Jerry it's not funny the only acceptable
response from George is to demand he
never used that joke onstage with a live
audience any other reaction is a
disservice to society this is the signal
who keeps a handkerchief the size of a
pillowcase in their pocket
this joker in seven seconds of audience
laughter and I don't believe for one
second a dog drinking from the toilet
has ever been that funny for climaxing
with the preposition let me just wipe
the sink and the bathroom floor because
the dog has been in there sloshing water
out of the bowl for a full minute which
is a lot of time in dog ears in a 23
minute show you can't have 12 minutes of
stand-up what's the deal with all the
stand-up great if you could ask a woman
what she's thinking you can in fact
literally ask a woman what she is
thinking that was an interesting green
you notice that George I'm sure Laura's
noticing this conversation I don't mean
to belabor this point but 53% of Jerry's
issues could have been avoided if he
learned to talk at a lower volume never
engaged while all of the other clues
about Laura's availability have been
gray this clue is neon run Jerry she
never mentioned being engaged it's
already complaining about it isn't
wearing a ring and said she was on an
emotional roller coaster struggling with
thinking in wee terms wolf the wine
cancel a boat ride and clamped the door
to your heart shut
a great guy really like you oh so he
wasn't being a possessive prick when he
called to make sure you've arrived
safely in New York and had a nice place
to stay that clears it up Laura is an
[ __ ]
women know what men want men know what
men want that's right this whole pilot
is a 22-minute version of a Mel Gibson
movie with slightly less sexism notice I
said slightly what do we want we want
women it's the only thing we know for
sure it really is
let's clear up another all-or-nothing
Jerry statement men don't always want
women sometimes they want men sometimes
they won't address in animal costumes
and Ferger their way toward pony land
sometimes they want to be left alone and
live with monks on the mountains all of
these by the way are okay this episode
does not contain in the lane I have to
remind myself that some birds aren't
meant to be caged if their feathers are
just too bright you do of course try on
when you bought here's a good idea have
a point
you're a backup come in to the coast we
get together have a few laughs any
questions yes America's Got Talent
you've got this guy's got time but God